En plus, on a 1 équivalence,
alors, les femmes sont 1 peu au-dessus, euh, des hommes,
à 73%, vous voyez,
par rapport aux soixante-et-onze pour 100 d'hommes
qui, euh veulent 1 préférence nationale. Donc les femmes
euh veulent la préférence nationale beaucoup plus.
Moins de 35 ans, on est à 70%,
plus de 65 ans à 73,
y a pas de rupture générationnelle non plus.
Et alors ?
Bon, c'est LR, c'est 97% hein, là on est on est au top,
euh au RN, 91%.
Donc les LR
sont devant en terme de préférence nationale,
euh que le RN reconquête à 98%, renaissance,
79% hein, si des des élus renaissent, c'est énorme. Oui,
ah bah oui, ce qui est beaucoup,
en tout cas par rapport à leur représentant,
ça je confirme.
Et Ops, on est à 39%, c'est le plus faible.
Europe écologie-les-vert,
46% des électeurs, hein, veulent la préférence nationale.
C'est pareil, c'est.
C'est étonnant
par rapport à ce qu'on entend ces derniers jours.
La France insoumise,
43 pour 143% des électeurs de la France insoumise,
euh ne sont pas choqués, voir même
veulent la préférence nationale.